just underway here at chase field
roberto castellanos on the bound for the
diamondbacks so good setup for the
mariners here in the first kyle seeger
steps in two for a hot streak here
he might get hot right there
say goodbye three-run jack kyle seeger
and they're off to a great start shaker
with home run number 32 takes his rbi
total to 88. talk about good timing yeah
it would certainly help this club we saw
hanniger three hits last night including
the home run starts off with the base
hit kyle because he ends up getting a
change up 83 miles an hour in the middle
of the plate and he barrels it up they
deliver a super mo head right on it exit
b low of 100
just shy at 400 feet i love that full
extension that's a beautiful sight when
he gets through a baseball marco
gonzalez has really turned his season
around this via 20th start 6-5 record
era just over four 107 and a third 83
strikeouts over 32 watts for marco
gonzalez one out walk ahead of carson
kelly
evacs trying to answer right back
carson hits a fly ball deep to left
field and that ball is gone
carson kelly answers back gets three to
two
they want a slug a little slug
outstanding full of borderline pitches
that went gonzales way earlier in the
sequence but he just floats that one up
there right in the middle of the strike
zone for carson kelly
not sure exactly what marmalajos was
doing out there in left field i thought
that ball was way out of here that goes
a couple rows up nice play by a man in
the front row carson's 11th home run
this year his eighth against a left-hand
pitcher maybe fairchild can deliver the
knockout blow only one for 13 in his
major league career they're loaded with
two outs
3-1 to fairchild
left failed that gets down for a base
hit young is home here comes peralta
diamondbacks grab the lead
stewart fairchild it's four to three
well that'll knock the rust off yeah
good on you stuart fairchild
hiding down there in that eight spot in
the lineup gets a fast ball down over
the heart of the plate and rips it into
left field
two outs in the inning everybody in
motion when that ball is put into play
he just stroked it nicely left field
kind of a top spin hooking like drive
and the rookie cal raleigh the catcher
leads it off for the mariners
line to first and christian walker's
there
pitch from castianas to gonzalez swing
at a miss strike him out there's the
first strikeout of the night for
castianos and two quick outs here in the
mariners second and now a base runner
for mitch haniger who's already had a
big series
on a curve ball he just stayed with the
breaking ball against even got him j.p
crawford here is off to a good start
he goes the other way big hit
kellnick scores
marmo right behind him and jp crawford
what a day three at bats
three base hits this one a two run shot
and the mariners are back in front five
four nicely done rbi's 39 and 40. yeah
that's picking your teammates up right
there gets ahead in the count fastball
on the inside corner and he barrels it
up feeling pretty good about himself as
he should and the mariners the lead
caleb smith came on relief of castianos
1-1
flat ball boy hits as well oh my
goodness space of the fence
thinking three kellnick gets it back in
to third
and he's out the back yeah
foul seeger standing with the play came
off right there he was going to be safe
now trying to stay with the play but
smith knew he's in trouble he's reaching
back marta cadella still looking for his
first hit of the series logan scored in
the first inning
knocked it into the right field corner
here cattell martay
has tied the ball game back and forth we
go it's five to five
the tenth of the year for could tell
martin we've got one down and away and
just went with it yeah change up just
off that outside corner our nationwide
vision centers eye on the game we know
cattell has big time pull power from the
right side
this time he goes right down the right
field lying into the mariners bullpen to
tie this one up outstanding
secret three-man homer in the first 3-1
high drive right field got big time
carry splash that baby
three-run armored kyle singer 8-5 lead
for the mariners his second three run
bomb of the afternoon home run number 33
and america back on top he threw him
that breaking ball again but this time
he hangs it in the middle of the plate
hits it out there into the swimming pool
he has 91 rbis 33 homers 406 feet
the heck of a dive they got took one out
runs it first and second josh rojas
fly ball
demo right there dylan moore makes the
catch two outs fine running catch on the
line drive
slicing away from him a little bit too
but he had a pretty good break on it
with two outs two on pavon smith will
pinch hit one and one here to pavemen
smith
popped it up jp crawford calling for it
more coming in and crawford will make
the two-handed catch high in the air and
that is out number three we go to the
top half of the ninth inning
tonight did a new pitch your right hand
to sean pop in the alaska usa federal
credit union
called to the bullpen
came on to get a couple of bouts in
relief monday against san diego former
19th round pick out a harvard
by the minnesota twins
we'll face the meat of the seattle order
kyle seeger will lead it off
slices that one the other way peralta
able to run that down for the first down
popping gets the first out now it's ty
france
chopper back toward the middle
fielded by young and he strains up and
throws the first to walker for a quick
second out here on the 9th
here's kellnick three and one on kelnick
that's lace to second
andrew young is right there
bottom nine coming up diamondbacks need
three
castillo little pitch here in the ninth
47 appearances on the air opponents
hitting just 191 against him with 45 and
two thirds he has 57 strikeouts over 15
walks
fastball will be in the mid 90s with
some run to a pretty good two-seamer
hard slider
here's mark tay home run in the fourth
one two pitch to martay swinging a
pop-up down the left-field line slicing
on the run dylan moore and he makes the
catch up against the wall down the line
gets the throw in quickly to second base
what a catch by moore over into foul
territory in the left field corner made
the catch braced himself up against the
wall that angles up toward the left
field foul pole
fine play by dylan moore
and here is carson kelly now a double
play
ends the ball game
ground ball seeger should do it there's
one
there's two rackham 8-5 final mariners
win it take the series five consecutive
road wins and with that w they tied the
oakland athletics
you